Jupiter Ascending led to one
star's reputation descending.
How did these actors win both
Hollywood's highest and lowest honors?
Al Pacino could've justifiably won an Oscar
for any number of his memorable performances.
He's been nominated nine times, for the likes of
The Godfather, Dog Day Afternoon, and Glengarry
Glen Ross. But it was his performance as a blind
and depressed former Army colonel in 1992's Scent
of a Woman that netted him his win. It may not
be remembered as the classic that some of his
other films are, but it did give us a killer
tango scene and an unforgettable catchphrase.
"Hoo-ah!"
Pacino has a knack for playing
likable bad guys, crooked good guys,
and big personalities, including the Devil
himself. He's also dipped a toe into self-parody,
especially later in his career. He does,
after all, have a very specific persona.
But he may have taken things just a little too
far with 2011's Jack and Jill. The critically
reviled Adam Sandler comedy stars the SNL
alum as the titular twin brother and sister,
and Pacino as the man who is inexplicably
smitten with Jill. Jack and Jill became the
first movie ever to sweep the Razzies, which
included Al Pacino as Worst Supporting Actor.
"It's not Al anymore. It's Dunk!"
"Dunkaccino?"
"Don't mind if I do!"
At the height of her fame, Kim Basinger
was one of Hollywood's go-to icy blondes.
It was exactly that stereotype that she
deconstructed with her performance as Lynn
Bracken in 1997's L.A. Confidential, for which
she won a well-deserved Supporting Actress Oscar.
Lynn is a high-end call girl in 1950s Los
Angeles who has gone under the knife and
dyed her hair in order to resemble
real-life movie star Veronica Lake.
After Basinger's Oscar win, she continued to
work, but mostly in movies that didn't match
her full talents. By 2017, she was playing second
fiddle to Dakota Johnson in Fifty Shades Darker,
the second installment in the Fifty Shades of
Grey trilogy. She played Elena Lincoln, a powerful
businesswoman who grooms a teenage Christian Grey
and turns him on to BDSM. Inexplicably, they're
still on good terms years later. The role didn't
exactly return Basinger to her former glory,
as she ended up with a Razzie and reviews
that compared her to a waxwork animatronic.
1997's Good Will Hunting wasn't Ben Affleck's
first movie, but it was the one that cemented
his status as a major talent both
in front of and behind the camera.
He won the Oscar for Original Screenplay along
with his buddy Matt Damon at the tender age of 25.
"How you like me now?!"
Affleck went on to win another Oscar,
this time for Best Picture as one of
the producers of 2012's Argo. He's
never been nominated for his acting,
though, despite turning in plenty of
praiseworthy performances over the years.
But Affleck doesn't exactly have a perfect
track record. 2003's Gigli was basically one
big punchline when it was released at the peak
of his and Jennifer Lopez's original tabloid
superstardom. Though the crime comedy about
a hitman and his hot babysitter starred two
of the most famous people in the world, it bombed
hard with audiences and critics. Affleck ended up
with a couple of Razzies, for Worst Actor and as
one half of Worst Screen Couple alongside Lopez.
There haven't been too many actors who have
won Oscars for foreign language films. In 1998,
Italian filmmaker Roberto Benigni became one of
them when he nabbed the Lead Actor statue over
Ian McKellen, Tom Hanks, Edward Norton,
and Nick Nolte for Life is Beautiful.
With its high concept narrative
and mannered performance style,
Life Is Beautiful isn't for everybody.
But if it is to your taste, then Benigni
is undeniably the film's heart and soul.
A few years later, he tried to apply that
same sense of dark whimsy to the classic
story of Pinocchio, to disastrous results.
Pinocchio was nominated for six Razzies
in total, and a 50-year-old Benigni was
named Worst Actor for his portrayal of the
little-boy puppet. Bizarrely enough, he would
go on to appear in another Pinocchio movie in
2019; although this time, he played Geppetto.
Halle Berry began her career as a pageant
queen and model with the kind of otherworldly
beauty that can be a double-edged sword.
It surely helped Berry break into showbiz,
but it also meant she had to fight harder
to be considered a serious thespian.
She reached the pinnacle of her career with her
Lead Actress Oscar win for 2001's Monster's Ball,
making her the first Black actress ever
to win in that category. Her performance
as a woman whose husband is on death row is
tortured, raw, and totally free of vanity.
"Black man in America, you
can't be like that! I'm tryna-"
When Berry was cast as the ferocious antihero
in 2004's Catwoman, it was clearly an effort to
capitalize on her Oscar win as well as her sex
appeal. Alas, the embarrassing final product
was met with hisses and failed to recoup its big
budget. Catwoman led the pack of bad movies that
year with seven Razzie nominations and four wins.
Though critics were generally kinder to Berry than
they were to the movie itself, she still took home
the Razzie for Worst Actress. Always a good sport,
she showed up in person to claim her
trophy and even gave a good-natured speech.
Marlon Brando was an icon of the silver screen
who brought method acting into the mainstream.
For his efforts, he was rewarded with two
Oscars. The first came in the heyday of his
stardom when he won Lead Actor for 1954's On the
Waterfront, in which he plays a once-promising
boxer turned dockworker who gets involved in
the criminal dealings of a corrupt union boss.
18 years later, he delivered his
best-remembered performance as mob
boss Don Vito Corleone in The Godfather, and
he was rewarded with another Lead Actor trophy.
Brando was Oscar-nominated six
other times throughout his career,
but his filmography is more
checkered than you might realize.
A particular low point came when he won the
Worst Supporting Actor Razzie for the 1996
remake of The Island of Dr. Moreau. He plays the
title character in a film that was resoundingly
rejected by audiences and critics. The
project was a disaster from the start,
with Brando experiencing a number of personal
setbacks, including the death of his daughter.
He was reportedly so checked out that he ended up
having his lines fed to him through an earpiece.
Sandra Bullock is one of the most popular
and versatile actresses in the industry.
She projects confidence as well
as humility as she effortlessly
transitions from drama to comedy to action. In
fact, she has so much range that she managed to
win the most high-profile awards for both
best AND worst actress in the same year.
In 2009, she starred in both The Blind
Side and All About Steve. The former is
a based-on-a-true-story sports drama
in which she plays Leigh Anne Tuohy,
the woman who adopts Michael Oher, a foster
kid who goes on to play professional football.
It was a huge box office hit, and
Oscar voters awarded it with a
Best Picture nomination and a
Lead Actress win for Bullock.
However, the day before the Oscars, Bullock
attended that year's Razzies to accept her award
for Worst Actress for All About Steve. As a
gag, she gave out DVD copies of that movie,
in which she plays Mary, a woman whose entire
personality basically consists of a bunch
of twee quirks thrown into a blender. She's a
crossword puzzle writer with a pet hamster and
shiny red boots who becomes obsessed with a man
she meets on a blind date and decides to stalk him
after he tries to let her down easy. So, not
exactly the most charming part she's ever played.
After years as a leading man, Kevin Costner
decided to try directing. His debut effort,
1990's Dances with Wolves, was received
extremely well. It impressed critics,
made hundreds of millions of dollars at the
box office, revitalized the Western genre,
and earned a whopping 12 Oscar nominations,
including three for Costner as producer,
director, and lead actor. He won for Picture
and Director, as Dances legitimized him as an
artist behind the camera and earned him
a blank check to make his next movie.
That next movie was 1997's The Postman, which
initially didn't seem too far removed from
Dances with Wolves. It's a sweeping neo-Western
directed by and starring Costner, but this time,
the drama takes place in an alternate,
post-apocalyptic 2013 after a plague has wiped
out much of the human population. Costner plays
the title character, who's not a mail deliverer,
but a migrant who stumbled upon an old uniform
and is endeavoring to restore civilization through
the re-establishment of a postal service.
Critics and audiences returned it to sender,
and Costner took home the "prizes"
for Worst Picture, Worst Director,
and Worst Actor. Those aren't his only career
Razzies either, as he'd previously won Worst
Remake or Sequel for Wyatt Earp and Worst Actor
for both Earp and Robin Hood: Prince of Thieves.
Leonardo DiCaprio was a child star who seamlessly
transitioned to one of the biggest names in the
industry as an adult. Over the years, he's starred
in more than his fair share of Oscar-nominated and
Oscar-winning movies. Some of them even won Best
Picture, but it took a while before he took home
a trophy himself for one of his performances.
That finally happened when he won Lead Actor
for 2015's The Revenant, in which he plays a
frontiersman who's brutally mauled by a bear.
Leo's Razzie arrived nearly 20 years
earlier. In 1998's The Man in the Iron Mask,
he plays two roles: France's King Louis XIV
and his secret identical twin brother Philippe,
the titular Man in the Iron Mask.
Though the film received mixed reviews,
audiences still bought tickets in part because
of the Leo fever that was in full swing in the
wake of Titanic's mammoth success. Razzie
voters weren't so enamored, though. Playing
both the hero and the vaillain sounds
like fodder for awards' attention,
but the only trophy bestowed upon him was
the Golden Raspberry for Worst Screen Couple.
"My twin. My blood. A fact which
has kept him alive until now."
Faye Dunaway began her career on Broadway
in the 1960s, and by the end of the decade,
she was playing one half of the outlaw duo
in Bonnie and Clyde. She received her first
Oscar nomination for that role, and her second
for 1974's mystery noir Chinatown. The third
time was ultimately the charm when she took
home the trophy for 1976's Network, an iconic
satire about a TV channel's sagging ratings and a
messiah-like figure who resurrects them. Dunaway
plays the network's head of programming who has
few, if any, personal or professional scruples.
Just five years later, Dunaway starred in a
film that generated significant controversy,
as she played screen legend Joan Crawford in the
1981 biopic Mommie Dearest. The movie focuses on
Crawford's adoption and subsequent abuse of her
daughter Christina. Dunaway's performance was
so over-the-top that Mommie Dearest was
eventually embraced as a camp classic.
But that ironic appreciation didn't
prevent it from collecting five Razzies,
including Dunaway's for Worst Actress.
"No wire hangers!"
To win his pair of Oscars, Mel Gibson
followed a similar path to Kevin Costner,
as he directed and starred in a rousing
historical epic. 1995's Braveheart ended
up winning Best Picture, and Gibson was
named Best Director in a bit of a surprise.
Braveheart earned praise for its battle scenes
but was dinged for its historical accuracy,
and audiences were split over
its use of graphic violence.
After a bit of an involuntary break due
to some racist and anti-Semitic remarks,
Gibson began to appear in movies again
semi-regularly in the 2010s. However,
he never quite regained his heavyweight status.
In 2017's Daddy's Home 2, he plays father
to Mark Wahlberg as a fighter pilot and
astronaut whose regressive masculinity and
neglect made his son into a problematic man.
Alas, casting Gibson as an outdated archetype
ultimately came across as more cringe-worthy than
self-aware. Unlike his Oscars for Braveheart,
his Worst Supporting Actor Razzie for
Daddy's Home 2 wasn't exactly a surprise.
Over Charlton Heston's 84 years, he went from
being a vocal supporter of the civil rights
movement to a conservative NRA activist. At the
same time, he also went from a stoic leading man
in action epics to someone who mostly did ironic
cameos and voiceover work in kids' movies.
Heston starred in a number of iconic
movies over the course of his career,
and he won his Oscar for one of them.
That was as the title character in the
1959 religious epic Ben-Hur, even though
his performance was somewhat overshadowed
by the film's breathtaking and
then-cutting edge chariot race.
Nearly half a century later, Heston won
Worst Supporting Actor at the 2002 Golden
Raspberries for his appearances in three separate
movies. Those roles were an English Mastiff in
Cats & Dogs, a heavily-made up Zaius in
Tim Burton's Planet of the Apes remake,
and a parody of own his gun-toting persona
in the romantic comedy Town & Country.
Jared Leto became a household name in 1994
as the swoon-worthy Jordan Catalano on the
canceled-too-soon teen drama My So-Called Life.
He soon made the transition to the big screen,
and he eventually got some Academy love when he
won Best Supporting Actor for his role in 2013's
Dallas Buyers Club as an HIV-positive
trans woman struggling with addiction.
His performance was widely
praised, although many felt
that a trans actor should've been given
the opportunity to play the part instead.
In the years since, Leto has taken on bigger and
bolder roles. This trend reached its apex with
2021's House of Gucci, in which he plays the
fashion family's black sheep Paolo underneath
pounds of prosthetics and makeup. Such flamboyant
choices came with great risk: his efforts were so
divisive that he seemed to have as much a shot
at being nominated for another Oscar as he did a
Razzie. He actually landed a nomination from the
Screen Actors Guild and several critics groups,
though the Academy passed him by, and the Golden
Raspberries declared him Worst Supporting Actor.
"The tiny little mouse is a character. Who knew?"
Younger audiences probably know Liza Minnelli
best for her hilarious guest appearances as
Lucille 2 on Arrested Development.
As the daughter of Judy Garland,
Minnelli managed to carve out
an impressive career for herself
outside of her mother's shadow. That includes
an Academy Award-winning performance as Sally
Bowles in 1972's Cabaret , the classic
musical about pre-World War II Germany.
After the 1981 rom-com Arthur, Minnelli had
a harder time securing the kinds of juicy,
triple-threat roles in which she so easily
shined. In 1988, she appeared in two poorly
reviewed films that together earned her a Razzie
for Worst Actress. In Arthur 2: On the Rocks,
she reprises her role as Linda, Arthur's now-wife
who wants to adopt a child with her supposedly
charming alcoholic husband. But it was probably
her role as a sex worker with a heart of gold
in the Burt Reynolds-starring Rent-a-Cop that
really earned her the Golden Raspberry. The film
received abysmal reviews from critics and the few
members of the public who saw it. It made a measly
$300,000 dollars at the box office, which didn't
come anywhere close to its $16 million budget.
After getting his start on the London stage
and filling small roles in period piece films,
Eddie Redmayne quickly became a leading man
and a critical darling. He won an Oscar for
his portrayal of famed cosmologist Stephen
Hawking in 2014's The Theory of Everything.
In becoming Hawking, Redmayne had to avoid
making it seem as though he was poking fun
at the late scientist's disabilities. By most
critics' and voters' assessments, he succeeded.
Just one year later, Redmayne attempted something
completely different. In the Wachowski sibling's
2015 trippy space opera Jupiter Ascending, he
plays the villain, Balem Abrasax, an alien rich
kid capitalist. It's sometimes said that acting
is about making choices, and boy does Redmayne
make some choices here. Chief among them is the
voice that he puts on. As he explained to GQ,
"My character had had his larynx
ripped out by this wolf man,
and so I made the slightly bold choice, which
I thought was right, of talking like this."
"I loved my mother."
Unfortunately, winning the Razzie
for Worst Supporting Actor that year
convinced Redmayne that his performance in
Jupiter Ascending wasn't very good. However,
fans of his have reclaimed his bold acting
as a brilliant stroke of artistic expression.
Sir Laurence Olivier's name is
synonymous with the craft of acting.
Even those who are only passingly familiar with
him could easily guess that he won an Oscar,
though they might not be able to guess for what
film. The master thespian was nominated for 11
acting Oscars over the course of his career.
He won a couple of honorary Academy Awards,
as well as a competitive trophy
for Lead Actor in 1948's Hamlet.
Like all famous actors, Olivier had to
carefully ponder what projects to sign on to.
Shockingly enough, this luminary of the
cinema chose unwisely twice in a row.
He received his first Razzie for Worst
Supporting Actor thanks to an ill-advised remake
of The Jazz Singer that also starred Neil Diamond.
As for Olivier's second Razzie, war
movies often do well at the box office
and on the awards circuit. They come
with a built-in gravitas, after all,
thanks to their subject matter and high
stakes. But that didn't prevent Olivier
from being named Worst Actor for Inchon!,
a Korean War epic that has a zero percent
Rotten Tomatoes score and is sometimes
cited as the worst war movie ever made.